the thrust of this decoration is that
canada will work with latvia and with
nato allies to generate and stage forces
in order to surge to a combat capable
brigade
canada will also establish
and lead the elements of a forward
brigade command and control element
and we will be ready to provide critical
capabilities to operations such as
ammunition and explosives air defense
systems and anti-tank weapons systems
with nearly 1400 deployed canadian armed
forces personnel operation reassurance
is currently canada's largest military
operation and we recently committed to
extend and expand operation reassurance
i would like to take a moment and thank
the canadian armed forces for their
leadership
in latvia as a framework nation
in the enhanced forward presence battle
group the bottom line today canada is
reaffirming our strong military presence
in latvia we are committed to growing it
and we are stepping up our contributions
to nato in a big way so we can keep
canadians safe and keep doing our part
on the world stage
and merci beaucoup
minister padres
so let's take a step back murray and
just
recognize that canada's commitment
is now in its next phase
to
latvia our first phase was the first
five years
where we have led successfully led and i
believe use the word perfect
um we have led the enhanced forward
presence battle group as a framework
nation
and as my colleague just mentioned we
have the largest number of allies in
latvia under our command
and so
in order to grow that
to brigade size it requires us to enter
into conversations with our allies to
understand what they can commit
respectively and so we will grow this
together with our allies not just in
terms of person power but also in terms
of the capabilities that i mentioned as
well as
operations and military aid ammunition
air defense systems anti-tank weapon
system this is going to be a
collaborative and combined approach and
this is the approach that canada has
taken to date to successfully lead the
efp battle group in latvia and i will
say that stands as an example
which many countries themselves point to
as a way in which nato's eastern flank
has been effectively protected and will
continue to be effectively protected
with the collaboration and cooperation
that we will continue to utilize going
forward and i guess i will just add that
you know in response to your comment
what is taking so long i think
really to be fair we have to look at the
increases
even in recent months of canada's
commitment to the eastern flank and
latvia in particular
we've added
an artillery battery to the enhanced
ford presence battle group in latvia
we've added an electronic warfare troop
we've added a retast halifax class
frigate to nato standing naval forces
we've added a maritime patrol aircraft
two tactical airlift aircraft with air
detachment and headquarters staff to
support multinational division north as
my colleague just pointed out so we are
continuing to increase our commitment in
latvia and that's what today is all
about
re-committing to an additional new stage
of our relationship with latvia and our
leadership role in latvia